STEPHANIE WONG: The global
markets move billions in value
daily, creating massive
amounts of data in the process.
As the volume,
variety, and complexity
of market and
alternative data expands,
financial data publishers
face mounting pressure
to modernize and deliver their
processes in an increasingly
latency-sensitive world.
And consumers are
demanding more.
There's a 60%
year-over-year increase
in demand for
alternative data sets.
And 90% of financial
firms are forecast
to use the cloud for their
market data in four years.
Right now, commercial
data publishers
have several ways of sharing
data sets with their customers
and partners, including
FTP, email, and access
to publisher APIs.
These can involve
a number of steps--
hosting data sets
on a remote system,
making multiple copies of
files for each consumer,
and letting consumers
fetch the data
with the right entitlements.
Unfortunately, this
can result in data
set fragmentation and
access control matrices that
are hard to rationalize.
On top of that, publishers face
operational overhead managing
multiple copies of
the same data, which
becomes expensive and hard to
scale up with consumer demand,
difficulty in tracking with
whom they've shared data sets
and which entitlements
are granted,
and increased
innovation friction
from the support of legacy
processes and infrastructure.
And it isn't easy for
consumers, either.
Getting the data
from the publisher
is just the beginning
of your journey
to making that data useful.
Once you fetch the data
set from publishers,
you're tasked with ingesting,
normalizing, storing,
and integrating it into
your own applications
and analytics pipelines.
This needs specialized
skill sets,
and there's usually a
long fulfillment process
to retrieve and get
value out of data.
Today, data customers
expect ease, flexibility,
and cost efficiency.
Datashare is an
open-source solution
available in the Google
Cloud Marketplace
to exchange commercial data
sets securely and easily.
It helps organize
third-party data,
making it accessible and
useful to exchanges, analysts,
aggregators, consumers,
and fintechs.
With market data in the cloud,
the entire financial services
ecosystem can come
together to exchange data
securely and easily.
With Datashare, data publishers
can load and transform data
once into the cloud and entitle
it across various dimensions
from a single source to
meet customer demands
and make sharing data
sets easy and secure.
You can even expand your reach
by onboarding your already
licensed and entitled data sets
in the Google Cloud Marketplace
under the Financial
Services Solutions
category, where new customers
can shop for and view your data
sets.
Here's how it works.
The data publisher
loads their source data
into BigQuery, Google
Cloud's fully managed,
petabyte-scale,
serverless data warehouse.
Through Datashare's fine-grained
access control policies,
publishers can entitle and
administer data sets and table
views.
Publishers control licensing,
while Google Cloud's
infrastructure takes
care of the data delivery
to consumers on Google Cloud.
With Datashare's scale and
centralized policy controls,
publishers can reduce
their operational risk.
Choose how you want to
share data through views.
Instead of making copies
of the same data set,
you can push data sets
quickly to existing customers
with data exchanges made
immediately ready to query.
And integrating product feedback
on the shape of the data
can be as simple as modifying
the embedded transformation
directives written in
SQL for your views.
For consumers, data is
immediately consumable
as soon as it lands
in BigQuery, relieving
the toil of downloading
and ingesting data.
You can easily access
entitled data sets by querying
right from BigQuery itself.
Once you're entitled,
you can rapidly
start to get value
out of that data,
unlock new revenue streams,
and with less time spent
on data wrangling,
spend more time
on solving business problems.
And Datashare isn't just
for financial markets.
It can be used for
retail, health care,
telecommunications,
and any time you
want to open up new revenue
streams by distributing
your data at scale.
To learn more, check out the
Financial Services Solutions
page, and stay tuned for the
next episode on selling data
on the Google Cloud Marketplace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]